[Music]
if we start from this sensuous being
into which that negative beyond
necessarily passes but abstract from
these specific ways in which
consciousness is related to it then what
remains is pure matter as a listless
aimless movement to and fro within
itself in this connection it is
important to bear in mind that pure
matter is merely what is left over when
we abstract from seeing feeling tasting
etc that is it is not matter that a seen
tasted felt etc what is seen felt tasted
is not matter but a color a stone a salt
etc matter is rather a pure abstraction
and so what we are presented with here
is the pure essence of thought or pure
thought itself as the absolute which
contains no differences is indeterminate
and void of predicates
paragraph 577 is going to sketch out for
us one side of this duality that we now
find within the victorious enlightenment
that is attempting to make sense of the
relationship between consciousness the
human being the individual and the
absolute being to which they are
connected and it might even be part of
in some respect
so Hegel says here we're going to focus
on the sensuous being a says we're going
to take a certain perspective on this if
we start from this sensuous being he
says into which that negative beyond
necessarily passes right so that's one
side of it but abstract from these
specific ways in which consciousness is
related to it then what we get is pure
matter pure matter he says as a listless
aimless movement to and fro within
itself that is probably not a way in
which we're accustomed to think about
matter but if you think about the
material world as it's revealed to us
whether we think about the science of
Hegel's day or you know the modern
natural science that we rely upon and
probably have some dim recollection of
from high school or college or middle
school classes matter is in motion but
it's kind of a meaningless motion it's a
motion that does things but you know
it's it's kind of a lacking significance
there are processes occurring but they
don't have any human dimension to them
you could say and this really is the
case and we see this being discussed
during the Enlightenment through the
movement of the development of Natural
Science and the philosophies that are
based on them here we might think for
example of John Locke you know prime
example so let's look at what Hegel has
to say and then I'll tell you how Locke
kind of fits in here so he says in this
connection it's important to bear in
mind that pure matter is merely what's
left over it's a kind of a an
intellectual residue but it's a very
important residue it
it's the substratum as lockwood say
right
it's a what's merely leftover when we
abstract from seeing feeling tasting etc
it's not matter that seemed tasted felt
what is seen felt tasted is not matter
but a color stone assault etc matter is
pure abstraction and so what we're
presented here is the pure essence of
thought so once again we see that we're
dealing with thought but we're dealing
with it under a certain guys so both
sides are actually going to be concerned
primarily with that thought so he goes
on and he finishes this up by saying
pure thought itself is the absolute is
what we're trying to attain is what
we're trying to make sense of which
contains no difference is it is
indeterminate and devoid of predicates
the void that we were seeing before
enlightenment dealing with but let's say
we focus on the problematic that's
involved here so we focus on the
sensuous side the sensuous being and we
say matter is what is most real the
substance that's underlying it all these
other things somebody like Locke would
say are what we can call secondary
properties color for example color is
really a matter of the the power of the
thing itself to produce within our eyes
and we would actually say within the the
nervous system itself these impressions
that we have that we call sense data
right or sense impressions and that's an
abstraction to by the way and it's kind
of interest in the Hegel instead of
saying you know we see we feel roughness
he says we feel a stone a stone is an
actual object that we identify is
something it's not just a color and then
he brings up a salt right so we taste a
saltiness but we also taste salt itself
and Locke's view and this is a view that
was held by many people during this this
time of the Enlightenment that were
talking about is that these these
secondary properties or qualities
they're not really the way things are
they're just a artifact of the fact of
our exercising the the agency of seeing
feeling tasting hearing smelling
whatever else you want to put in there
as senses upon that who knows what it is
matter underneath it and they did try to
you know list primary qualities as
opposed to secondary qualities there was
an attempt to try to reduce this down to
something you might say like geometry or
numbers but it becomes very very
abstract and you're also stuck with
another problem so you look at things
through an electron microscope right and
you're like oh wow look at you know what
would Abby's eyes look like or what a
cell looks like or you know what a salt
crystal looks like you're getting really
really far down I mean you don't even
need an electron microscope to do that
you can do that with a little one that
you had in in biology class right but
let's say you go as far down as you can
and you're doing digital imaging imaging
is still working through sight is it not
you're still understanding the spatial
arrangements of things through how
things are impacting on your eyeball so
we want to get away from even that and
say that there's some sort of pure
matter underlying things that maybe we
understand solely in terms of
mathematical relationships well that is
about as abstract as you can get and
that's what's really underlying this
focus on the sensuous if you want to be
scientific about it if you want to try
to get to what's at the bottom of things
it's not enough just to say oh well you
know we got the thinking side of the
Enlightenment and then we got the sense
perception side of the Enlightenment
because the sense perception side of the
alignment those people want to know what
what is going on with this as well
one party of the Enlightenment calls
absolute being that predicates lists
absolute which exists in thought beyond
the actual consciousness which formed
the starting point the other calls it
matter if these were to be distinguished
as nature and spirit or God then the
unconscious and aimless inner movement
to and fro would lack the wealth of
developed life which would make it
nature and the self differentiated
consciousness which would make it spirit
or God the two as we saw are absolutely
the same notion the difference lies not
in what they actually are but simply and
solely in the different starting points
of the two developments and in the fact
that each sticks to its own point in the
movement of thought if they could
disregard their own starting points they
would meet and would recognize that what
to the one is so it pretends an
abomination and to the other a folly is
the same thing for to the one absolute
being as pure thinking or is immediately
for pure consciousness is outside finite
consciousness the- beyond of it if it
would reflect firstly that the simple
immediacy of thought is nothing else but
pure being and secondly that what is
negative for consciousness is at the
same time related to it that in the
negative judgment he is coppola holds
together as well as separates the terms
it would come to see that this beyond
characterized as something existing
externally stands in a relation to
consciousness and is thus the same as
what is called pure matter the missing
moment of presence would be gained the
other enlightenment starts from sensuous
being that abstracts from the sensuous
relation of tasting seeing etc and makes
that being into a pure in itself into an
absolute matter into what is neither
felt nor tasted this being has in this
way become something simple without
predicates the essence of pure
consciousness it is the pure notion as
implicitly existent or pure thought
within itself this insight does not
consciously take the reverse step from
what is what simply is to what is
thought which is the same
what simply is does not take the step
from the pure positive to the pure
negative although after all the positive
is pure solely through negation while
the pure negative is pure is in its own
self self identical and just for that
reason positive or again they have not
arrived at the notion found in de cartes
metaphysics that being and thought are
in themselves the same they have not
arrived at the thought that being pure
being is not something concretely real
but a pure abstraction and conversely
pure thought self identity or essence
partly is the negative of self
consciousness and therefore being partly
as immediately simple is likewise
nothing else but being thought is thing
hood or thing hood is thought
paragraph 578 is quite long and there's
a lot going on in it so we want to
follow out the entire course and find
out what this reference to Descartes at
the end is going to mean for us but I
actually want to jump all the way to the
very last sentence of it because I think
there's there's a formulation here that
Hegel is providing us that helps put
this into perspective quite well he's
got this thought is thing hood or thing
hood is slot right well we can call a
key a stick arrangement a key azzam is
this X you know thought is is thing hood
thing hood is thought you know people do
this all the time when they're trying to
pull off you know verbal sleight a hand
on us you know there's it's actually
spoofed a lot of movies as meaningless
talk but in some cases a key azzam is
not meaningless it's actually looking at
the relationship between these things
very very closely and so the rhetorical
structure sometimes is representing a
conceptual structure and that is the
case here with Hegel we can talk about
two parties of enlightenment to use the
phrase that he introduced a little bit
earlier and is now bringing up again in
in this paragraph and we can call one of
the parties the party of thought and the
other party the party of thing hood
because they're focusing on those and
Hegel wants to show us that with
whichever one you start with you're
actually going to end up incorporating
something from the other party so he
starts out this this paragraph by saying
one party of the Enlightenment calls
absolute being we're gonna call that the
party of the absolute that predicate
lives absolute which exists in thought
beyond the actual consciousness which
formed the starting point so you're
trying to think the absolute you're not
assuming that your own consciousness is
absolute but you're trying to extend it
to a thought that's out there that would
be greater than your own and would would
somehow make sense of everything if you
could just
I thought that's one side of the
enlightenment and so if anybody ever
tries to tell you that the Enlightenment
is you know a purely secular or
something like that they're if they're
they don't know that what they're
talking about
there is a great amount of speculation
within the philosophy of religion and
indeed within metaphysics itself that's
carried out by these Enlightenment
figures on the other side we have the
materialist essentialist
side the side that's very this worldly
and Hegel says the other party of the
Enlightenment calls the absolute matter
so we have again the party of thought
the party of the thing so he says if
these were and that's a big notice that
he's using the word if right if these
were to be stated be distinguished as he
says nature and spirit or as God if you
like if we want to use an older
formulation if we were going to
distinguish these as nature and spirit
then we would have a problem he says the
unconscious and aimless inner movement
to and fro would lack the wealth of
developed life which would make it
nature so if we're going to try to
identify this with you know nature and
God an earlier formulation right God is
something being beyond nature or perhaps
permeating nature immanent and
transcendent at the same time nature
itself understood as the cosmos we would
be lacking he says the the
differentiation we would be lacking the
connections and so the Enlightenment
gets away from nature as it was
understood previously just as much as it
gets away from God as it was understood
previously not totally disconnected from
it still using the same language too by
the way but reinterpreting it Hegel goes
on and he says the self differentiated
consciousness would also be lacking
which would make it spirit or our God
now here's what Hegel wants
point out for us this is an important
turning point that gives you kind of a
glimpse into Hegel's own perspective
Hegel is in a certain sense of pantheist
he's not he's not your usual sort of
pantheous but spirit does work itself
out throughout history in the world so
he says the to that is nature and God
are absolutely the same notion now does
that mean when he says they're
absolutely the same notion that we
should really just use one word for them
no they are covering two different
aspects which have to be brought
together in a single notion so in a
sense they're the same notion when we
get to the end of the story but they're
not the same notion for everybody who's
talking about it during the
Enlightenment he says their difference
lies not in what they actually are but
in the different starting points of the
two developments the two sides of
enlightenment and in the fact that each
sticks to its own point in the movement
of thought so you can start on the side
of nature and focus on matter and then
you're going to wind up actually on the
other side that's the kicker here or you
can start out on the other side with the
party of the absolute thought god and
then as you analyze it you're gonna wind
up on the other side as well but you're
really talking about the same object
according to Hegel so in a lot of
respects the people within the
Enlightenment they weren't all on the
same team they weren't all on the same
page or if they were they didn't realize
that they were they were quite often
talking past each other and engaging in
polemics which turn out in a certain
sense to be unnecessary right from our
perspective at the end but from their
own perspective these were intractable
problems so he goes on and he says if
they could disregard and again if right
if they could disregard their own
starting points they would meet and
would recognize that - what the
that what that what to the one is so it
pretends an abomination right
what's the abomination looking at it
from the side of the absolute or God
this emphasis on matter or nature is an
abomination right or the other side a
folly looking at it from the side of the
part the the party of matter or nature
to bring God in there is foolishness why
do you need to bring in this unnecessary
hypothesis to paraphrase one
Enlightenment figure so he says these
are actually the same thing so he says
to the one absolute being is in its pure
thinking it's immediately he says for
pure consciousness it's outside finite
consciousness it's the negative of it so
you've got a consciousness that's
thinking and you've got the absolute
that is thinking and the absolute is
sort of thinking with a capital T right
and he goes on and he says it would
reflect that the simple immediacy of
thought is nothing else than pure being
this is the party of thinking but it's
going to show that it's really just
being secondly that what is negative for
consciousness is at the same time
related to it
that in the negative judgment that is
holds together as well as separates the
terms what's he on about there right so
the copula is the is if I say God is
rational all right there we have a
positive judgment being made if we say
something like we are doing with with
the Enlightenment God is not humano
centric right God does not have the same
desires wishes ideas that human beings
do now we have a negative judgment that
is the Coppola there is what is
connecting them and Hegel wants to
remind us as just go back to this
passage he says the net the couple of
holds together as well as separates the
turtles in order to understand what it
is that pure thought or the absolute or
God is
we can say what God isn't and then we're
we're maintaining God or the absolute
and whatever it is that we're denying or
affirming the opposite of in one one big
thought I mean here's the kicker right
who's able to think these thoughts the
the consciousness that is finite are
they really able to make make sense out
of this the answer is yes which means
that consciousness is not as finite as
we we make it out to be or at least some
people's consciousness is not so he says
if it would realize this it would come
to see that this beyond characterizes
something existing externally stands in
a relation to consciousness and thus is
the same as pure matter so by the way of
determination we wind up with I started
out with the absolute as opposed to
matter but the way I'm treating the
absolute is just the same way as those
guys on that other side are treating
matter something external to me it is a
thought that is external to my thought
it is a thought that's in some respect
greater than my own thinking we're gonna
have some problems with this later on in
the Hegelian framework because in order
for me to have the judgment that that
thought is outside of my thought and is
at the same time thought either the
center of gravity moves entirely over
there and my thought is just this finite
puny thing in which case how do I
actually know that I'm getting the the
whole scheme right or in a certain sense
I'm taking that thought into myself well
we're not here we're not at that point
in this this paragraph now let's look at
the other side he says the other
enlightenment starts from sensuous being
right and then as we saw in the previous
paragraph it starts to say well let's
strip away the predicates of sensuous
being because you know seeing is really
just this relationship between the
organs of the the eyes and the nerve
herbs and stuff like that and how the
light is impinging on it so colors not
really real it's just a subjective it's
in my head what's real is the shapes out
there and we're gonna abstract away
predicate after predicate after
predicate and by way of doing that we
wind up treating matter as if it's the
absolute without qualities right he says
the other enlightenment abstracts from
the sensuous relationship of tasting
seeing etc and makes that being in to
appear in itself into an absolute matter
into what is neither felt nor tasted now
what is absolute matter is it something
you can encounter in the world here's
the kicker Hegel doesn't come out quite
so much and say this but until a little
bit later that's something that's
thought you're not encountering pure
matter you're not observing pure matter
you are thinking pure matter when you're
saying that everything boils down to
that this is a very important
realization right so he goes on and he
says we make it into a pure in itself
right and he says this being has in the
way become something simple without
predicates the essence of pure
consciousness it is the pure notion as
implicitly existent or what pure thought
within itself so whether we start from
one side or the other side if we
actually follow out their train of
thinking which they are not completely
conscious of we see they're really
talking about the same thing and they
resemble each other much more than they
differ from each other so any sort of
effective relationship that they have
with the opposite side you know you're
the party of folly you're the party of
abomination that's all nonsense
that's all misdirection they don't
understand themselves Hegel would save
so he goes on and he says this insight
does not consciously take the reverse
step from what is what simply as to what
is thought which is the same as what
simply is it does not take the step from
the pure positive to the pure negative
from the pure positive a man
to the pure negative of thought although
after all the positive is pure slowly
through negation while pure negative is
pure is its own self self identical and
it's for that reason positive there's
Hegel's getting into his typical
dialectic of you know that which is you
know existent repels itself from itself
we've got you know various forms of
negation and positivity and I wouldn't
worry too much about that here but now
we jump into something really
interesting it's pretty rare that Hegel
in the phenomenology brings up other
philosophers or really anybody at all he
almost never names a name right but here
in this passage who does he bring up
Descartes so he says they have not
arrived at the notion found in de cartes
metaphysics that being and thought are
in themselves the same now isn't that
strange to say historically when we
think about Descartes do we place him in
the middle of the Enlightenment no we
place him at the beginning of the
Enlightenment so what would this mean
this would mean that Descartes one of
the fathers sometimes some people call
him the father of modern philosophy some
people say even a modernity has been
inadequately understood by many of the
people who are taking him to be their
guiding light during the Enlightenment
the people on the side of the absolute
the people on the side of of matter
opposed to each other don't grasp
something that Hegel takes to be at the
core of decart's idealism remember can't
Hegel's predecessor figured decart
as one of the great idealists prior to
taught so Hegel is following up on that
what is the notion found in de cartes
metaphysics being and thought are in
themselves the same they are the same
thing
they have not arrived at the thought
that pure being is not something
concrete
real but a pure abstraction when you're
talking about pure being and you strip
away all the predicates and you're
trying to think pure being you're
turning it into a thought right being
and thought are the same thing that
you're the thinker grasping that pure
being as thought so he says
conversely pure thought self identity or
essence partly is the negative of
self-consciousness and therefore being
pure thought is also being you've turned
it into an in itself something beyond
you not part of your consciousness and
then he says partly is immediately
simple it's nothing else but being so we
get back to this this formulation
thought is thing hood or thing hood is
thought the two of them are actually the
same I almost said the same thing that
gets a little confusing if I do that
right they're really the same notion and
so the call for enlightenment to arrive
at the truth of itself which is what
this section is about is going to have
to be to bring these somehow together
but right now we've got two parties both
of whom think that they have the
monopoly on the truth of the
Enlightenment and that the other side is
fundamentally getting it wrong